[Music]
thank you foreign
[Music]
foreign
Crossing
um so I've had a very long week uh very
stressful week and I didn't want to play
Alan Wake
I didn't want to play anything scary or
stressful so I thought today I'm gonna
play Animal Crossing because
I've been getting back into it again
recently I'll explain why in a second
um
what I've been working on in my spare
time
Animal Crossing so yeah I last year I
stopped playing Animal Crossing before
Halloween and now obviously it's
Halloween
geez it's loud
it's Halloween season and I'm like
I want to get all the cool Halloween
games
I need to go to the shop every day
because I want to get sweets my Animal
Crossing is still so rudimentary it's
like embarrassing compared to like all
the other people
but I like it I'm still not at five
stars but
it's fine
foreign
[Music]
happy Thursday Nelson
hi young man Nelson here hey mantas
Hey Kevin
af196
hey clay we're playing Fatal Frame on
the Halloween stream which is the first
year so this room hasn't really changed
from when you saw it last I think you
saw it last I don't know if you did I've
added a few extra bits and Bobs Spot the
Difference uh let's go change our
clothes
[Music]
ah it's good to see you too Nelson
uh okay so let's let's change our hair
first of all because I only have my hair
up because I was wearing Wings the other
day I was wearing wings and a duck
outfit it was
oof it was the height of fashion
um but we're not gonna do that now
comparing dozero and everything I think
that's why I used to love the old
um Animal Crossing game and then I kind
of stopped playing this quite early and
I honestly think the main thing is
comparison it's just I could see my
friend's Islands I could see people on
the internet's Island and I was like
mine is so crap but when I played it
before it wasn't it wasn't even about
that it was just about you know enjoying
your own Island
uh where is my witch's hat
[Music]
be down here
[Music]
aha there it is should we wear a black
one
I did wear a red one with this before
but let's keep it simple that's why I
black one dude
[Music]
I could wear red tights No One's Gonna
see them
holy sex
and I should have a little little red
booties
I prefer these ones
that's what these will be like a a
peasant witch
[Music]
yeah I I'm only playing this now because
I keep picking up Animal Crossing and
then putting a bird down again and it
can be very addicting
so this is the room I don't thank you so
much of last time it was like my Forest
study and now I've kind of kitted it out
a little bit more
[Music]
okay so yes please
we've got to get to the shop before 10
so I've got to do my rounds
um but yeah I'm slowly thinking about
things that I can change
[Music]
of like this is why I roast marshmallows
let's see
now perhaps going on there there's like
a little table thing this is where I cut
my pumpkins see I'm gonna cut the
pumpkins and Chop Chop Chop Chop carbon
pumpkin this is where I grew my potions
uh and this is actually based on a guy
what's his name crab there's a guy who
was in The Occult he's like extremely
well known in the occult and he lived in
a house near uh well right next to the
Loch Ness and some people say the Loch
Ness is due to his occultism uh like it
was like a demon that he raised
which is pretty interesting so I thought
I'd do the same thing
so
we have our spooky spooky woods with a
bloody Lantern there
[Applause]
[Music]
Crowley yeah I think that was it
because I watched them
I watched a film which I always can't
remember that was based around it this
is my man he hides behind the trees and
there's a spider there too
foreign
to control them and then to
um bring himself to a station like
Enlightenment so he could talk to his
Guardian Angel something so
he was trying to do something good in
the end but by raising demons
oh yeah
oh yeah
oh crap
oh
turn down the game a bit more for you
guys
let me know how that sounds uh
Rapture incline that get brings you back
every single day
[Music]
[Music]
okay okay
[Music]
also I must apologize if I'm a little
bit low beat today it's
um my btmi but it's my first day of the
month and it's been extremely hard
[Music]
[Applause]
and I just get really tired
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
in the PC
but I do I have just enough
[Music]
okay so up here is where I'm going to
put my zen garden because I put it I'll
show you where where I've put it so far
I need to get rid of this dude maybe
I'll eat my apples
I'll get rid of this tree no don't drop
them
there's there's little things like this
that are the reason why phone people
stop playing Animal Crossings like can I
not just eat all of the apples but I'd
have to eat one apple at a time and you
would have thought that they would have
he would have fixed this stuff if they
wanted to so they obviously don't want
to because it is a Time sink and that
means that you spend more time
just like social media
thank you don't worry it gets better
it's just
annoying isn't it
[Music]
okay great well do I really want to pick
these up now
maybe I'll put them up when I do my zen
garden
okay let's
drop Jessica for now because we're gonna
end up just moving all of this over
there later okay bye oh and so over here
I can even get over there there's some
stuff here
all I want to do
is have you know how people do
Illusions and it makes it like there's
like a tiny town and you're on this
gigantic Mountain I want to do that down
here
uh but I need I need to get like tiny
cars and tiny houses and stuff for us so
how people make their Islands so good
they have so much stuff
yeah if you didn't know uh this capture
card saved me by a few of uh in the chat
so you can say thank you to everyone
I do have a PS2 so I've been wanting to
use it on that as well just need to
figure out what PS2 game I want to play
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
sure I'll take the floor lamp
okay
um
[Music]
[Music]
almost as adorable as in-game Yahoo
she is she is pretty darn cute
but I had I had the spooky music in my
spooky forest and they all sing the
spooky music even though there's other
music on the island but they all maybe
they just know it's spooky music and
they know it's spooky season but
um
[Music]
oh
spooky sorry I didn't need to no I
wanted to talk again
I guess oh yeah I need to look at the
sea as well oh here we go so we're
looking for
any Halloween
things uh wooden block a table
I don't want that
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm gonna slowly make the whole entire
eyelid
s
actually
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
but yeah so we can put
these here hopefully
that's my eyes uh and then I bought a
little
[Music]
drinks machine to go with this snap
machine
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
just a nice thing to do every day to
unwind I think that's why I haven't
gotten very far in my oh yeah look I I
changed for the swimming pool is I put
it down here
um yeah I think that's why I don't get
very far in my designs because I just
play it usually for about an hour a day
for less than that really
and then I move on and it's just like a
nice little way to usually unwind
afterwards I have a little fishing poem
now lovely fishing fun
and I want to put a fence all around
here and do my secret garden
[Music]
where's Godzilla here
[Music]
okay
[Music]
oh is anyone making things does
sometimes say like
make little DIYs and they might be a
Halloween theme
I like this guy
[Music]
this is a very important question red
ball or Monster pick your poison
I actually I don't think I've ever tried
monster and I hate Reddit
I gave him a drinks machine he put it
here I can't see it when I walk in but
that's so cool because it's his room is
like a little office so I gave him a
drinks machine
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
as well
exciting day oh I also started to play
Animal Crossing again because it's
having a major update
uh and
the word on the street is that
um the cafe is coming back so if anyone
played any of the original animal
costumes
[Music]
um
they've also made it much easier to run
away from the Beast which I very very
much enjoy it's like impossible to run
away from bees
um
but yeah what they've done uh oh hello
where did you get here
[Music]
um
what's the same oh yeah in in Old Animal
Crossing games
um KK cider used to come in the little
cafe which it's nearly Escapes Me Now
um but yeah I used to come to the cafe
every Saturday or Friday something like
that and it's really cute because you
can have coffee
and then when this game came out and he
just comes in front of the plaza I think
everyone was a little bit disappointed
including me so it's really cool to see
that it might be coming back and I think
it's coming back as part of the museum
so it's going to be a
a room inside the museum that is a cafe
um so yeah
[Music]
I want you to assess
ment oh my God I got all four what
it's only four a day
okay
of course you already have them I got
all of them I found all the dinosaurs
okay bye
I'm thinking I also could they have
randomized oh sorry I just I just hit
the microphone could they have
randomized the speech a little bit more
as well
[Music]
I was looking forward to buying
something new although that hammock
though that was cool
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
enough to go into the shop for my
clothes the clothes shop
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
so now I buy sweets
hey Luis Luis Luis
one of those
hey Michael Garcia
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
come on
dude
take my weed
[Music]
nope that's good
[Music]
there's gonna be more sticky things to
make sure
I have five thousand pounds
so I can put that in the hole
[Music]
foreign
I do like the blue orange one
what are you talking about Michael
it's appropriately festive the one with
the skeleton
I think the festive of dead I imagine
crazy mango
oh are you still talking about Red Bull
a monster I thought you took my little
character in here
[Music]
he always comes through
something
because your room is way too oh
I also done this test he's one of my
stars
uh let's see
Bye Bill
okay
[Music]
hello
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
maybe I can find a nicer pattern
[Music]
mm-hmm they're all for like Signs and
stuff like you put blood on it
put Nessie on it
I could put I want to believe in aliens
on it
um
[Music]
colorful
pattern oh
so many options tartan
hey gaming with Malachi welcome to a
super chill stream
I'll show you some of my spooky things
in a second
thank you for the Super Chat you made my
lights go crazy I don't know if you can
see them that well but they did go crazy
I promise you
foreign
[Music]
always so late
[Music]
it's a little chickens on it
[Music]
flowers not pizzas hmm
[Music]
Hulu girls Hula Girls
foreign
[Music]
let's just go simple plain and simple
let's just actually now kind of like
this let's just keep it like this
should we make a lamp
two green ones
two orange one oh this is where I carve
my pumpkins by the way
it's Malachi
we're gonna try and make a
[Music]
spooky light
[Music]
oh it's really sad place is sad spooky
like
oh
it's like
it's hanging
that side
uh yeah oh no wait
wait
honey
one more pumpkin one more orange
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay fine I'll just have to water my
pumpkins and wait for them
so cozy it can be like very repetitive
and it's very long so you can't skip
talking and oh my God the
um us isn't great like you can't
buy things in bulk or do things in bulk
really and you can't stack in your
inventory much you can some things and
everything and not things like flowers
which you really probably should be able
to do that
um but it is definitely a chill game and
I think part of the reason why the
developers don't want to allow you to do
all those things that I just said is to
keep the pace very slow which I'm
guessing is partly to do with the vibe
but also partly to do with how long
people spend playing the game
so uh monitoring I guess
um
what do I have here I want to cattle
piano bench floor lamp oh yeah
[Music]
I put these down wherever wherever you
used to fit okay
[Applause]
little things like this as well
please
I wish it could be like the Sims and you
could just go top down
uh you can do it inside the house to
prepare but when you're decorating the
island it can be a bit of a ball like
right
oh yeah right let's put the music in the
air and then we'll be done and then I'll
show you what I've been working on
no I've never played ghost of sushima
shushima It's amazing And also fitting
that I've been getting as I saw my ship
this year it's making it way more
awesome I know I love stories I like so
I was thinking that the other day
because James has definitely inspired me
to do things in my real life and uh I
think we need to focus more on that
because people are always like oh
games are making kids stay indoors and
all these things and shorts they do have
a negative impact but they also can
inspire you to to better yourself in the
real world
you know expand your imagination and all
that kind of stuff what so I already
have that song
[Music]
yeah the music in that room with the in
my little study I thought I study very
like study Forest room it's very nice
it is nice
okay let's see the hammer
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is well we don't know what they are
you just know they're leaves
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh I'll go in
get a little bit more money
one non-functional replica of The
Witcher 3 silver sword the one from
Promotional and into screen that's so
cool
[Music]
wait see your
what's this I have three blades now just
got on the last one last month
that's so cool
I haven't played it in a while actually
I was looking at my I've got a sticker
on my PC today and I was like what can I
find another one
oh
yeah
I definitely would have because I'm
still playing that uh the main the big
last DLC and it's so pretty I literally
every time I play it I just can't go
over how pretty it is especially
considering how long it's been out for I
can't believe how pretty it still is
foreign
[Music]
bye oh that was nice
okay
[Music]
see you later alligator
okay
so
what we are going to do now
is
if I can close this one
I'm going to be showing you what I've
been attempting to work on in my spare
time
um I don't know how many of you know but
I'm making another
um music video in a game engine and I
thought I should probably show you uh
yeah as always very intimidating but but
I should probably show you because it's
interesting and I'm quite liking the
direction that it's going so I want I
want you to have a look
before I end this stream this is going
to be a shorter stream as well by the
way
um but I'll just get it up I'm working
um still working in Unreal Engine 4. I'm
not going to move on to five until
I need to make like a realistic
environment because I'm real engine five
um allows for crazy amounts of triangles
which means that you can have very
detailed meshes and environments uh you
can make great looking stuff and not
have to worry as much about the
performance which is brilliant
especially for someone like me who does
not model and therefore does not model
efficiently if she ever even does
um but I'm still on ue4 at the moment
because it's what I know it's what a lot
of my plugins are in and
I wanted to keep this simple
oh hey Jamie so yeah Jamie and I have
got the song ready for this video so now
it's just riding on me and I'm probably
gonna get it done like by next month I
think because it's not it's nothing
spooky or scary so it doesn't really
make sense to release it this month
anyway
um it's actually very much the opposite
just spooky it's scary it's it's very
nice and chill
so
okay
let me
show you this
huge jazz
the song is complete that's later right
uh what what do you mean
the song is complete though yes
Okay so
um
this is
a little environment
it is modeled by the very talented
Braden if you didn't know him already
some of you might know him as onion
Knight or onion boy
um Onion Man perhaps
onion King some might even say but
anyway I I have been having some
troubles with um textures uh because
it's not uh unwrapped
but I think it's fine because this is
just gonna be for
a music video and therefore I don't have
to bake lights
um for performance which is good uh
yeah but I think it's it's a really cute
little environment to play around with
and basically what I'm doing now is I've
I've set up the environment and then I
created all the materials so these are
all the materials that I created
and I can show you
I I'll get it up here
I'm gonna get I'm gonna get up my messy
um
documentation
that is a I what would you call it like
design
stuff
um
Direction
I don't know or something like that feel
it too oh it is but
so
there's this
uh so this was kind of like the feel
that I was going for with the 3D model
uh I think Braden killed it
it's awesome it's great and then these
were the Vibes so when I got them
um it was all uh basic materials I
remade them and I wanted to follow like
a kind of a Lo-Fi
color palette
so I went kind of for these like more
pastely colors very chill very calm very
relaxing I love I love this green so
that's why I have made the walls of the
screen
but then I I like the idea of having
some pops of color in there as well uh I
was watching a playthrough of Hades and
I noticed they have little pops of like
really bright vivid colors
and it works very well in Hades it looks
really really nice
so that's what I have tried to do here
um I I wonder if I can just turn off
so there's a skylight here
because I because I'm in the middle of
all of my uh lighting this wasn't how it
looked initially initially it was super
super bright
and I haven't finished it properly yet
so if I turn that off it's quite dark
and I can make it lighter as well
here so it's on two so I can like boost
it
oh
that's not good
let's go to my skylight
so
because it's quite a small area you can
probably notice there's a lot of like
dark shadows and stuff
but that's okay because I'm putting in
loads of
lights Point lights spotlights and stuff
like that
because I wanted to kind of be
not daytime but like the morning time or
the evening time I'm not quite sure what
yet but one of those dawn dusk one of
those moments
going on I think will be quite nice
um so I've got the Skylight has a bit of
pink in it because that is the color
profile
uh sorry I haven't even been looking at
the comments I've just been like
rambling on has anyone said anything
art Direction
yes
uh jari I have I made a game a while ago
called Perfection I'll put it in the
chat if you want to play it
um but honestly I haven't had the time
to make a game since University which
is it's like I guess sad but it's it's a
lot of commitment to do especially when
you have a full-time job
it's something I think about a lot
because I think I'd have to quit like
doing streams and YouTube videos and
stuff but here's
uh and all my other things like writing
and
singing
um
here's my game LOL it's free
um
yeah making someone else's game
yes I work as a technical game designer
um associate but fingers crossed okay
promotions soon which would be nice
um so yeah I I do this as a job but
we're not not this I I do technical
pipelines as a job
um that's kind of what I do in my
day-to-day
but it's cool I like I actually have a
lot of fun just setting up the
environments that's why I'm quite
enjoying doing these um music videos in
unbuilt engine because I feel like even
though I'd love to make a game it's kind
of like
a nice
um
thing to do instead because it means
that I get to keep on singing and you
know working on the next EP with Jamie
but also working on my own skills as a
game developer outside of my job as well
because I don't get to do stuff like
this in my job which is cool
um and who knows where it might take me
in the future but yeah so what I did for
my technical setup of this I guess is
I've got loads of different materials
but they're all instances of a base type
of material so you have
your basic basic material and then uh
you'll have your
um what is called scalar yeah scalar
parameters
um for metallic specular and roughness
and then this means that you can make
um
material instances of them and then
whenever you do that this is the new
material instance you can open it up and
then you have all of these scalar
parameters that I set up and you can
make it different
um so this just it's always a really
good way it's always good to start like
this so that if you have anything that
you need to change to I don't know of
the quality of all of your materials you
can just do it to your base material and
then it will update all of your
instances this is the kind of stuff that
I do in work to be honest just think
about workflows
um and then I've got a glass instance
I don't make materials on work though so
this isn't you know this isn't what I do
so I'm learning a lot to be honest
um it's good that I'm doing a low poly
style though because I think that's all
I I could do but I'm quite I'm quite
enjoying it I tried to use uh quicksil
for this but again the texture map so
these none of this was unwrapped and if
I put any
um any textures on it you can see all
the seams and it just doesn't look
doesn't look very nice so I thought you
know what I'm actually quite happy about
that because this means that I really do
have to stick with my limitation of it
being low poly
um basic textures because I literally
can't do anything with these models that
would be really
um
what's the word
complicated
so yeah but I I spent probably too long
on this color scheme and I'm quite happy
with it I think it looks really pretty
um
so here's the phone I got I did try out
because I was having fun with uh the oh
no see it's just too much isn't it I put
a uh
uh quixel material on just on this
little button bit here and it's got
little fingerprints all over it but it
kind of looks too much now I'm not sure
if I liked that or not
I don't know
brass fingerprint material see this is
the material it's really cool because
it's got It's got the fingerprints all
over it but I just think it looks a bit
too much
we can have a look where is it
brass instance
let's find the fingerprint material
oh it's because I multiplied it
okay let's try this how does this look
sorry I was just updating my twitch
information
no so I haven't tried Unreal Engine 5
yet Kaiser I'm gonna do that whenever I
need to make a realistic
game because of
because of the awesome amount of
triangles that it can handle uh which is
great for someone like me who is not a
modeler and
does not know how to make performance
models uh so I'm very excited to try
that out when I can
um
but yeah this is just keeping things
simple in ue4 so I've got uh this is
actually my Skylight is doing this light
on the floor but then I have got an
extra Spotlight here and then I have
used here which I was extremely excited
about
um a light function material which is
like an animated material on the light
and it kind of looks like cars are
passing by so I'm hoping that I can go
in there and mess around with that and
have it kind of stop and start so that
it's a bit more randomized on when the
material plays but we'll see what I'm
able to do with that
uh
my idea is I need to get a light in here
and what I want to do I've got some
pages to go into these books from my
actual Diaries and stuff like that so
I'm going to update that and update
what's on the screen and on the phone
and I've got these textures
uh oh that's just a plane uh where's the
text
uh yeah so I've got this Polaroids that
I'm gonna turn into
uh well Polaroids and what I was hoping
to do was to record myself on a green
screen and get myself in here but now
that I'm looking in I think it's gonna
look pretty crap to be honest so instead
I'm hoping I can get myself projected in
different parts of the room so I'm
thinking
I can maybe uh have myself in this book
and I'm going to get loads of different
cameras and have them set up to be
looking at different parts of the room
so I can have me in the book and then I
can use post-processing to put on a
special
overlay of me to make it look like I'm
all Liney or something you know like I'm
a sketch or something and then have me
on the phone which could be quite cool
uh
maybe have me in a a
Polaroid maybe not I don't think it
would work uh on the laptop
but yeah we shall see and then I'm quite
I'm quite proud of this so this is I I
need to finish it but this is outside
and I think it looks really cool through
the window because of the glass
kind of made this like frosted glass
material and I just think it looks so
cool with the neon signs and stuff but
yeah I just need to
uh to finish all of this and get them
all going out
and then hopefully
they'll look really good
but yeah
and I left it off last time I was just
putting in the lights I think it's gonna
take me a little while
but
I don't know I'm just
having fun with it it's quite a chill
thing to do just lighting an environment
quite like it because you go here and
then you go okay what kind of light
would I like using wall Boomerang maybe
I do wall inverted V oh no that's way
too much maybe not
maybe we
do something a bit lighter what about
spread out what's that
that looks better
I can't really notice that's good
I'm going to do one of these for each of
these lights
it's gonna be so or maybe I'll just do
one for every few of the lights
um yeah maybe that's a better idea
just see how it
and then I did make a quick blueprint
the other day
um for yeah I made this candle blueprint
and it's got here inside the blueprint
it's got a point light and a spotlight
and if you
have used Point like ticks that uses a
point light but then you can untick it
and it uses a spotlight
um
and then when you play
should I haven't even tested it
yeah so it's the Max and Min intensity
is is changing
at uh
what it's a timeline that I've made but
I definitely need to go in and
fix it up a bit but I think
that's quite effective we just need to
change the Max and Min because that is a
mental
yeah I need to get rid of this mirror
yeah that's not so bad
and I can use that on different parts I
also want to need to put in the
particles in this scene as well so
there's still a lot of that so a lot
that I need to do I wasn't sure if I
should show you today because I I don't
know I feel like it's slow progress but
I'm also quite proud of it at the same
time so why not show you
Spotlight we don't really want to
Spotlight oh
mental
I love inserting myself into art too
kind of looks like the outside kind of
looks like a mix between Sun Hill and
Bioshock interesting yeah I can see why
he says Sun Hill because of the The Fog
so as I was watching a tutorial a
lighting tutorial the other day and
um they said to always put fog in your
scene because the light picks it up and
like bounces through the fog and then I
did it and I was like damn that looks
good like let me show you
um
okay so this is the fog
and fog density is it what was it [ __ ]
height fall off
yeah I guess it would be
okay so that's zero and that's one
oh no that's 0.5 so say if we put like
20 fog density in here
only go up to ten apparently
um so look at my room now
and look at it now
okay that's that's correct I thought it
was someone before
even point one just makes a lot of
difference I think
just gives it a bit more atmosphere
especially outside
this is why it takes so long so
spend ages
I thought I made the clouds a bit
denser
no don't want that
I guess they just kind of blend in
so I made the sky
the same colors as this I tried to
try to release
it doesn't really have the orange
can't really see it
it's more subtle
anyway let's get back to these
so yeah I've used one of these on the
phone as well the phones are the massive
material but then it's one of this on
the phone and it looks like it's
spreading out from the phone
and fun fact a lot of this stuff is
actually what I've got
in the flat
so this is my sippy cup here and it's
it's on it's on this
uh my old laptop that I used to have
before I started uh
streaming
I should probably get this in a mess of
color
sorry an immersive um
cereal
[Music]
[Music]
what material do you have
phone glass what a year
oh
don't look at this it's already messy
it's really messy don't look at it
uh what color
wait
is anyone in the chat gonna come to the
Halloween stream do you think maybe
Maybe
purple it's like a dark purple but
we'll see or maybe I could do blue
let's have a look
oh no sorry wrong one
oh
oh screen
I don't know if I like that color
what color do I want the screen
hmm
foreign
I don't know
Maybe
maybe not
Maybe Pink
the switch is green
Maybe Pink
we'll see leave it like that for now
sweet
hey Linea
yeah I'm really looking forward to the
Halloween stream it should be good
I've uh I've got uh I've got now film
well part kind of an outfit on the way
it's not really
but I've got something on the way to
wear which I'm very excited uh and then
we're gonna play Fail frame and some
games with friends I've got um back for
blood downloaded so we can play that
that'll be fun
uh I think we're gonna play phasmaphobia
as well
just cause
apparently it's had
um some updates
maybe a white plate
gosh
I'm gonna take forever just to
do these little things but right back
area
can you even
aha this is what I mean about the UVs
okay
diva
that'd be fine we'll just leave that one
like that
okay
let's do another one
15.
degrees
angle
oh interesting
of course we can't have both because
I'll overlap that's fine I wasn't too
sure about these ones anyway
let's remove you bye
they were like giving a little sparkly
sparkly
but uh yeah I'm not sure how I felt
about the sparkles
do a thing
I don't know
since it just it just puts a strip down
the wall
yeah
hmm
okay
if I just choose a few good ones that
work for these
then I can duplicate them of course
because it's spread out why did I use
that
stupid
uh
maybe this could work
oops where did you go
hmm
it's not going to connect right
connect
I was watching um
uh what they called what are they called
Hocus Pocus the other day
and it's it's not as good as I remember
but it's still it's still good fun I
used to love I used to love that film
when I was a kid
if I couldn't sleep it was the film that
me and my mum would watch until I could
finally fall asleep
which is very wholesome
but yeah I loved loved that film
okay that's an interesting one
uh John why did you hide your videos of
little nightmares one
um
I don't know if I intentionally hid them
uh what I might have done
is it might have been oh you know what
I'm gonna
I think that was at the time when I
didn't want to have unedited videos on
my channel
because I thought it was unprofessional
and would damage my Channel or I don't
know
so they are probably unlisted or in like
a playlist
but I'm sure they're still there
uh I mean I can have a look
let me have let me have a little look
through my YouTube
because a few times now I've had kind of
like a
crazy moment with my YouTuber I'm like
what am I
when am I and then I just
move things make new playlists remove
things I don't know I'm just I'm going
crazy and the only people who get to see
everything is uh
a patreons because they I don't delete
anything for them but
I don't know
they're all Nightmares come on
nightmares playlist
apparently I don't have any little
nightmares playlist
hmm
okay yeah
here they are so they are unlisted
let me have a look
I'll be in a playlist what playlists are
they in
live stream live night little nightmares
fold playthrough and I had a playlist
like where is the playlist then
YouTube why you be like this let me find
little nightmares
if I search it it won't find it but I
know it exists
foreign
I'll find it
little nightmares there it is
share coffee okay okay I hope you're
still there because I have the playlist
here's a little nightmares
one fall play through playlist
it's all live so sorry there will be
rambling but it's there if you want to
watch it
but you are right they were unlisted
because yeah I was I was um
embarrassed
by the fact that they weren't
um edited I thought they weren't good
enough
but I'm slowly learning that I should
just leave things up for you because
some of you enjoy them and that's what
matters the most
okay I don't want to put too many
on these things
I don't want to overdo it
a bowl oh that's quite cool Bowl
it's a bowl okay now let's just spread
them out a bit
oh this is a stupid line one
Starburst starvest
cute
Starburst
Starburst
why do you still look weird you just
look weird what's wrong with you
maybe I should not put a beam on this
one
maybe I'll put the starburst
of this one
I'm sorry if this is really boring
it's it's very quiet isn't it it's much
quieter than most of the other streams
but
there will be screens to come don't you
worry
I also am in talks with a really
talented artist about some
um emotes
which is extremely exciting I've been
thinking about getting emotes for so
long
and uh she's called sleepiest
on Twitter and Instagram sleepiest
designs or sleepiest
and she's really good and yeah I'm very
excited
it's gonna be like scared ones of me
screaming
and what other ones the scared ones me
screaming there's gonna be wannabe being
brave so you can tell me when I'm being
brave because I want you to do that
and uh
I asked her maybe if there's a
possibility we can do one for balls
but I even I'm not quite sure how we're
going to do that one so
that might not happen
uh but yeah and then obviously a singing
one as well because we've got to have
that haven't we
wow this is a lot of lines
can I maybe put on
this one
is that too much oh geez it's not way
too much
interesting maybe if I
puts the intensity down
[Music]
Maybe
yeah exactly mantas Jenny does make
really good
good Arts
oh my God blown eardrums that's such a
good idea
that's such a good idea I love that I
love that so much
we I might have to change one of them
then
what do you think well what one should
we change
um
me screaming me singing me like being
brave or the Bulls
emote
which one should be changed to a blown
eardrum I love that idea
I think that's hilarious
I didn't want to keep turning these I
can put them whatever way I would like
I figured we needed like a music one but
maybe we don't need a music One
or maybe we don't need the brave one
maybe I'm just like being too nice to
myself
because the blown eardrum one would be
hilarious to see
uh the screaming or blown air drum both
have the same effect
oh yeah that's that oh yeah that's true
that's true
so true
so you would want either the scream or
or the blown ear dramas is that what
you're saying
interesting interesting I mean there's
no reason why we can't obviously ask
more in the future either
I say we I mean me
add some purple lights with the pink
what like these lights
we could always try
let's have a look
I have my light my light palette here oh
my my color palette but as soon as I
I've got to put it on my other screen
because as soon as I get a click it'll
leave again but yeah I can I can do some
purple let's try
is that too dark yeah it probably will
be
it's this one
what do you think of that
it's quite nice actually
good Shout
we can make some of them purple and some
of them some of them pink yeah it's a
good idea
thank you very much
Michael
I'll do that I'll do that
let's just get these figures figured out
for now this will be my one task and
then I'll stop the whole stops stop the
stream because you would have seen you
would have seen that was my main goal
for you to see and just have a little
little glimpse into what I'm trying to
make on the side at the moment
trying to make this kind of like what I
do make sense in a way it's it's so
difficult because I do so many different
things
and I just wanna
find something that makes sense does
that make sense does that make sense am
I find something that makes sense it
makes sense do I make sense do you make
sense nothing makes sense
but yeah I just want to make something
that encompasses everything I suppose
but that is also
feasible to do in in the amount of free
time that I get uh
I think this is like the the best thing
but even these take so long and it's
it's so difficult I mean
I'm not gonna lie I was actually
thinking the other day of like should I
do her Masters
because it's crazy like I have a job and
everything
but I really just miss making things and
honing my craft and
when I went to UNI I went to UNI to do
like mixed media arts using game engines
but I wanted to do like installations
and and
interactive pieces that were more like
art than like your
typical video game
uh and I never got to do that and it's a
real shame
because I was very much excited to do
that
but I don't know it's it's it's a tough
one
because yeah I do I do like my job but
at the same time it's
it's not very like creative it's very
technical which is good because it's
teaching me so much and it's really nice
to have technical skills
especially
to fall back on you know
don't have to worry as much about job
security if you have technical skills
but I miss all the creatively fun stuff
that's why it's nice to have some
something on the side to work towards
yeah you might be right there mantas
ah it matters yeah
man I wish I wish I knew someone
business-minded or I wish I was
business-minded
it blows my mind how people how people
do like set up their own businesses and
Studios and stuff
it's so cool but also at the same time
absolutely bloody terrifying and
you know I just think I guess
the first step is to come up with a
feasible idea of the things that you
would make or even if it's just a game
like what what is your vertical slice I
suppose to then go to Publishers and ask
for money and stuff
foreign
oh man I wish I wish that were possible
just yeah just take a year out
see what happens I mean I understand why
it's not though
because you can't just take a year out
and be like I'm gonna try this thing and
then it's gonna work out and you're like
hey I'm back hey I'm back and they're
like where have you been
a time and trying a different thing and
it didn't work out so now I'm back
I know I mean if they need you why why
not I guess I don't know I don't know I
don't know
corporate life
hmm do I want this here because the
Polaroid
movie there
okay
now
if we get this
color
and we put it on some of these
I mean we could go
no
every odd one
here's a Sam Richmond
what a funny name sorry I didn't mean to
make phone really
um I I'm actually not making game I'm
making like a cinematic I guess it's
it's a music video uh I made an Unreal
Engine
so it's a very small uh environment and
I'm gonna be using green screen to put
myself in it I'm just doing the lights
now and I need to finish off the outside
of it
uh but yeah it's just going to be a
little three minute cinematic uh for a
song that uh me and producer Jamie at
Horizon Productions of meat so
it's gonna be cute hopefully it's gonna
be kind of like life li-fi Lo-Fi Vibes
although the song isn't low five but
I want the song well the song is very
cozy and
chill
so I wanted the video to reflect that
and these are definitely Chill Vibes so
I'm liking it
let's move this one over
okay
how does that look
hmm
not sure about these ones
overall
does it kind of like fairy lights
doesn't it
because they do bounce off the walls
like that
maybe just went a bit overkill on some
of them
but
not so bad
but it's not green eyes slip stable ah
we can't risk it I don't want to get in
trouble by the Spotify people or the
music industry before
oh
[Music]
I don't know
I think the song sounds good if you
think it would benefit from that though
Jamie like
try it let's see how it sounds but I'm
quite happy with where the song is at
the moment
so yeah that's what I'm gonna be doing
uh I'm gonna be hopefully finishing the
lights
by
this weekend
hopefully
and then I can
well I'm gonna be recording myself this
weekend as well and then I can put
myself into the scene but yeah this is
where I'm at so far I'm quite happy with
my color palette I need to get rid of
that bloody mirror
um I need to finish the outdoors as well
but that that should be easy because
it's just a matter of copy and pasting
the buildings really and just getting
them to go down here
um
yeah I'm quite I'm quite proud of it
quite excited to share it it should be a
nice chill happy cozy little oh yeah
there's a duck which is uh
a little Easter egg a little yeah a
little Easter egg I guess
for those of you who know you know
anyway
that is probably all I'm going to show
you because I don't want to bore you too
much with me just changing Shades and
stuff all the time
so yeah I hope you enjoyed watching
I know it's okay it's more of an inside
joke to myself
okay okay fair enough fair enough
a peek into the mind of the AG man do a
model of a dwarf star
hello Peyton sorry but I'm leaving now
I'll awake next week I can dig that got
some nice metal Tunes in that game oh
yeah because you you put some in the
Discord didn't you oh yeah let me put
the Discord in the chat for anyone who
wants to get involved in the Discord who
isn't already in the Discord
foreign
there you go so you can join the Discord
if you'd like to
um that's where I'll keep you up to date
on everything coming out or the live
streams I live stream every Thursday at
8 30 p.m BST uh next week we're going to
be starting on Alan Wake we're supposed
to play that today but we didn't I
couldn't bother so so uh we'll play that
next week and then on Saturday the 30th
we have a charity Halloween stream I'm
really excited for it so that's at 3pm
till about 10 11 ish so yeah I really
hope that some of you can make it but
either way I will see you next week
so thank you for spending the evening
with me looking at my Animal Crossing
town looking at my current personal
project and uh
I'll see you next week I'm going to say
goodbye to who I can see in the chat so
goodbye said NATO goodbye Kieran white
goodbye mantaz goodbye rexolite
goodbye 8196
um
goodbye Jamie charity Halloween Bonanza
goodbye Michael Castilla has been so
sweet spending time with you again oh
that's really cute
um
goodbye rexellite goodbye Kieran I'm
saying goodbye to everyone again all
right goodbye pay hunt
uh goodbye everyone and six goodbye I'm
just saying goodbye to everyone again
now all right okay I'm gonna leave I'm
Gonna Leave okay thank you again I'll
see you next week uh have a lovely day
or evening have a great weekend too okay
see ya bye
bye